the layer hyalurpan show
[Music]
sponsored by step finance
your go to d5 portfolio manager on
solana
luna if you're just getting into bitcoin
it's the perfect place to start
[Music]
hey guys anna welcome back to the leia
higher plan show as you can see we are
here in beautiful miami and i have a
very interesting guest it is four-time
kickboxing world champion
entrepreneur i'm gonna go through the
list okay full-time kickboxing world
champion entrepreneur um he owns a bunch
of casinos made some i don't know like
multi-millionaire you introduce yourself
better i can't do it okay uh
yeah basically all the things you just
said yeah four-time kickboxing world
champion i guess i'll say i'm an
entrepreneur multi-millionaire
all-around nice guy i agree around nice
guy around my sky and yeah we're here in
miami so
good to see you young lady good to me
good to see you again it's always good
to see you all right let's go into this
because this is going to be totally
unfiltered i have a bunch of topics that
i want to go into
um for context we met about over a year
ago i think it was yeah we've known each
other a while i've seen you out in the
twitter space like taking over and
flexing on them i've seen i've seen your
little videos like it's bitcoin going to
go up or down da da and you do well and
you're growing and that kind of thing so
we've known each other a while yeah yeah
and ever since we met i've had a bunch
of questions um and i'm not gonna filter
and i'm not gonna filter anything no
sugar coat so i want to jump straight
into this so you might so you might hurt
my feelings that's what we're saying
basically basically that's what's gonna
happen you see that people at home you
see
don't let this the pretty face fool you
she's out here to break my heart hurt my
feelings so i've got to be careful here
don't let the tough persona fool you all
around nice guy all right let's jump
into this so one of the biggest things
that you're known for is women
and uh it's it's 9 30 in the morning
we're talking about chicks we're talking
about chicks i'm happy today because
look one of the first things that really
confused me about you when we met was
the fact that you're not a one woman man
okay that's not completely true
explain it's not completely true i'm not
saying i couldn't have and enjoy the
company of a single female for attorney
i'm saying my point is that truthfully
if we remove all the garbage and the
fairy tales if men are true to their
biology no man is completely utterly a
one-woman man that's my point there's a
societal expectation which has been
placed upon humanity and then we have a
biological and evolutionary imperative
and the male evolutionary imperative is
not to have one female now there are
some dudes out there who are gonna
disagree with me but those are dudes
they got low testosterone they're not
the big g they got no money they ain't
nothing right that's different but any
man who's actually in a position of
status since the dawn of human time
every single king every single sultan
all of them had more than one chick
that's actually the natural human state
so the point i was trying to make is
even though i am a man of god and i try
and keep myself close to christ
right because i'm such a
because i'm such a nice guy
my point is any man who has the means
to attract or solicit the company of
more than one female
likely will enjoy this the company of
more than one female does that make
sense it doesn't i i respect it no
judgement
the confusion that i have is your jet
setting right you're here you're there
and we'll get to that but how does that
work right because at the end of the day
women want
love emotion and attention and if you're
jet setting and if you have multiple
women
how how does that work practically i
don't have any women it was just an
observation i don't have any women i'm
like
i can't lie
no um
i know what you're saying women want
love and they want attention those kind
of things and yeah i travel the world
but i really don't think that it's
difficult to uh maintain a relationship
purely based on
if if if the connection is true then the
physical presence doesn't have to be as
prevalent let's get it that way right
there's lots of soldiers go to war and
they have a wife at home who loves them
but that's different because they're
going to die for a cause let's just i'm
going to war i'm out here on the street
so you think i'm making all this money
but what do you do but like you're not
fighting about all i do is fight my life
is a fight what do you mean i'm not
fighting a battle i'm fighting a battle
against the oppression of humankind how
are you doing that how am i doing that
i'm the only person who didn't cowered
out at the beginning of this imaginary
scam demo i'm out here literally
resisting the enslavement of man what do
you think i'm trying to make all this
money for more cars no i'm making money
specifically so that i am
to a degree at least ungovernable i need
to be you on it but that's on an
individual level and i take care of my
people
people why people so this is what i mean
it's not like i'm out here doing nothing
i'm out here on the streets i gotta go
miami i gotta see you go get this done
from here i gotta go dubai make some
more money i'm running around the world
i'm doing very very important things and
if i had a female if i did because of
course i don't a man of god blah blah
blah if i had a female she would have to
be very understanding of the fact that i
am a man of machine with a purpose and
you know some there are some missions
should be allowed to come with me on and
some missions she can't come it's not
safe for females out here
i'm out here i'm all right i managed to
get him next to me i got you i got you i
got you leia you're okay but you know
but otherwise you've got to be careful
women are you know what and i don't want
to look like a misogynist
as usual misogyny
is like is okay to a degree okay what
degree let me know give me a number at
10.
i think it depends how we're defining
misogyny right yeah like how do you
define misogyny
realism realistic
a lot of misogyny is just realism you
know like if you're a realist then to
some degree you're going to be a sexist
but is that sex so is that sexist or is
that just being real
right because like if it's a fact yeah
exactly is that sexy exactly so
i i personally
i don't like traveling the world with
women i think it's one of the most
frustrating
things a man can possibly do
okay imagine you had to travel around
the world and you had to take a
three-year-old with you
you'd be like where's my three-year-old
how's it eight i have to make sure
they're safe gotta bring all their stuff
it's exactly the same with the chick me
and my brother we're spartan right we
can just go walk up at an airport oh
there's no flight for 11 hours sleep in
the airport terminal don't eat don't
sleep one bag on our back old school
soldiers we don't care with a chick it's
all i need food i need water where's my
stuff my case is 55 kilo oh i forgot
this foundation i need to find this
foundation it's it's horrible i do agree
with you but if i if i haven't eaten i'm
not good yeah so women are effectively
children
we're just different to men we're not
children a child couldn't sit here and
have this conversation with you
women have to be monitored and
maintained and maintenanced effectively
like a child would when it comes to not
like a child yeah same exactly the same
it's the same it's interesting yeah like
listen if i'm going to go to iraq
afghanistan all the places i've been to
these places i go with tristan we're
battle ready
ak go off we start running like a chick
will all be standing there ah no that's
true what would happen if you didn't
have tristan
my life would be drastically different i
think that all men in fact i'd say the
actual plague of western nations today
is that all men
lack a natural masculine support network
i don't think it's just about me having
my brother i think it's the fact that
most men out here don't have a genuine
masculine support network they don't
have men around them that they can
not so much confident but men hold other
men accountable it's very easy to be
brave when every man you talk to is
brave and it's very hard to be brave if
none of the men you speak to a brave but
what would you do if you didn't have
tristan well then i'd have to get a
masculine support network outside of
tristan which i've already done and
created myself so it does exist but um
i don't think it would completely change
who i am but certainly having my brother
was important in my formulative years
because if somebody like didn't like me
or something didn't like me it didn't
matter because me and my brother we
didn't care we're big we're hard to kill
we don't doesn't matter if you like us
right so one of the things i like about
you is that you didn't come from money
correct and so
you're very real
thank you
as a compliment you are real thank you
you did a video where you were like i'm
out camping i don't need all the luxury
i don't need all this ambiance so um
people don't know that so talk to me
about that um growing up was it luton
you were born i know so i was born in
washington dc oh america yeah and i left
when i was nine and i grew up on a
council of state in lieutenant yeah
council estate in louisiana yeah and
from the ghetto
yeah that is the ghetto that is the the
english ghetto so talk to me about that
though what was that like and how long
were you in in that kind of situation
yeah so i i left america when i was when
i was around nine and i lived in luton
until the age of
wow until you're 26 yeah a long time
yeah but i was kickboxing right my fight
gym was there and i was fighting from
there and before i finally managed to
get out but i grew up in a council state
in luton and i am so thankful for it the
best
possible thing that can happen to
somebody is to be born broke and become
rich if you're born rich life's terrible
if you're born broke and you stay broke
life's terrible but to be born broke and
become rich
is a beautiful thing because truthfully
money really
isn't all that interesting what's
interesting about money is thinking back
to all the times you had no money i love
to go spend 25 000
for dinner not because the money twenty
five thousand dollars for dinner all the
time yeah no yeah no but yeah all the
time we're in miami where you been
great places but i'm not putting down
25k for dinner because you're a chick
and females don't pay anything for
anything they don't in miami they don't
pay anything yeah unbelievable but yeah
no women have to pay right but there's
certain places you can definitely do
that and the point is the food isn't
worth it
and it's not worth 25 g's but the whole
fun of it is just thinking back to when
you never had 25 grand in your life i
never had any money in my savings
account i was completely flat broke so
it's the juxtaposition that makes it
interesting there's no light without
dark so i love the fact that i was poor
those are some of the in some ways they
were some of the happiest times of my
life life was simpler back when i was
poor i'm not going to buy into more
money more problems i'm not going to say
that being rich isn't fantastic because
it certainly is however when you're
broke you have a very simple singular
focus which is what it should be just to
make more money but now my focus is more
spread out because i really i really do
not need to make more money that's the
one thing i do not need more of
but there's so much more to this story
so i'm not gonna let that go so there
was hardship right and your dad wasn't
always around there was a story with
like the hair
the whole haircut and you told your hair
doesn't matter and all this like really
formed you yeah i want to hear about it
i want to hear about the hardship okay
well the hardship my whole life was
hardship and to some degree i try and
make sure my life retains some degree of
hardship
uh my my father was the og i was raised
by probably the best father on earth i
really genuinely but he wasn't around
but a father doesn't have to be around
this is a big mistake this is another
big mistake especially among the
conservatives and the trad cons and all
this crap the idea that a father needs
to sit around like a second mother to
make a child healthy is a fallacy in
fact i'd say it's detrimental to the
child i see all these dudes out here
they have a kid and they basically
become mother number two why the mother
keeps the child alive as a father it's
your job to be impactful you need to
guide you need to be a role model you
need to be a superhuman everyone should
look at their father like a superhero
that's what you should genuinely view
him as it's hard to be a superhero of
your home every day arguing with your
wife changing diapers that's not what
man should do a man should rock up teach
lessons be impactful and it's more about
quality as opposed to quantity of time i
saw my dad once a month
he was out on the streets he was pimping
hustling my father was a chess
grandmaster he's traveling the world
playing chess he had all his girls he's
doing whatever he's doing when he came
home it was an impactful time whether it
was a positive impact or a big argument
or whatever never was i ever around my
father it was a low energy environment
that's not who he was as an individual
and i remember every single second spent
with him there's a whole bunch of dudes
out here
and chicks their father's home all the
time fine but if you're home all the
time you're going to lose to a degree or
mystery doesn't matter how cool you are
as individual you're home all the time
always you're not going to have that
magical power as opposed to whoa dad's
home i'm telling you the biggest mistake
fathers make is that they let the woman
convince them that to be a good dad they
need to be there all the time that is a
complete lie fathers never did this we
were always at war or down the coal
mines or away working this is the way
it's always been for the for humanity
right the men were away doing important
things now the man's at home changing
diapers they're called punk
why does that mystery matter of course
it matters because life is mystery life
is a whole it doesn't mean anything that
that's that's just a lot of um beautiful
exciting words like life life is
absolutely mystery i'll tell you why the
mystery matters because for a female to
retain her attractiveness to a man there
has to be a degree of mystery that's the
first thing so we're talking about
household where even the woman truly
respects her man
there's a bunch of dudes out here a
bunch of people are married who are home
every day low testosterone levels
they're cut out and they're going to
disagree with me fine but it's the truth
a woman is more attracted to a man who
gives a little bit of mystery let me
give you an example let's imagine we're
on a date uh lesser magic
and you asked me my job and i said oh i
do this and this and this and this no no
no what would you actually say you
wouldn't say this and this give me no i
wouldn't i would never tell a female my
job let's say what would you say let's
say i run casinos i don't casino
right
let's say so i picked you up
we're in the lambo we go out for a nice
dinner i say i run casinos
alternatively you say what's your job
and i say
i look after my people that's my job
but the point i'm making is the story
you're going to construct in your head
is actually going to be more interesting
to you than the truth you're going to
say what my man just 25 grand on dinner
pulled up in a 400 000 car looks after
his people what does that even mean and
it's going to be more interesting to you
when you watch a horror movie
what what scares you is not the ghost
that's on the screen it's the thing you
don't see
it's just walking and there's noise you
don't see anything and then bang it
comes out of nowhere that's how human
mind works a degree of mystery is
extremely intriguing to the human mind
so it's extremely intriguing to the
female for her man it's the first thing
it's also extremely intriguing to the
child for their father
dad's home oh no the whole dynamic of
the house has changed everything's
shifted dad is home he's been away and
now he's home whether it's positive or
negative that has an impact on you has a
genuine effect on your psyche i see so
many fathers walk in the house and the
kids are just playing a video game dad
walks in
they don't give a [ __ ] is that is that
parenting are you a good dad now because
you're home every day that's why all
these dudes are pumps
no one can question what i'm saying when
it comes to being a father or parenting
because i was raised in a very specific
way and i'm one of the greatest men on
the face of the planet
so i know it works i'm the product of it
right so if i had a son it would be my
duty to be out here traveling the world
making money having impact being a
fantastic individual that is the primary
focus of my existence as opposed to
sitting there with my boy all day every
day i can come home every two weeks with
a story boom and he'll be like that's
the boss like yes dad is the boss is
that
a minimum or like a maximum so for
example you said just come home every
two weeks your dad came home every month
do you think there's a time an amount
where you could be away too long
no
not really i mean
it's hard to quantify in a very very
specific quantifiable way right it's
hard to quantify but the point is if you
make a large enough impact you could see
your i if i had a son i could see him
once a year
but my son should want to emulate me you
should want to be me he is me so i have
to live a lifestyle which is worth
emulating this is the difference between
kings and peasants and this is the
problem with the world today
99 of the men including 99 percent of
men are going to watch this interview
all the crypto dorks all these dudes all
these losers they're peasants they have
a peasant mindset
when a king had a son he wasn't staying
at home changing diapers he was
conquering new lands and going to battle
for the name for the bloodline to set an
example for his son to graze into right
dad's out here he's conquered this he's
built this castle he's out there he
slayed those people killed those people
i'm the next i gotta go do something
that's how a king raises a son by
example a peasant raises his son the
same way a female raises his son
the [ __ ] is this apparent that's not
being a dad it's it's it's not being a
dad this is all new age garbage and it's
the femme centric mindset which is
controlling men to the point where they
can't be honest amongst themselves and
i'll tell you another thing and this is
a study that's been done
the higher your testosterone level the
lat the lower your natural interest in
babies this is an actual i can't imagine
that yeah
and what happens is when a man sits
around a baby all the time his
testosterone level naturally decreases
because it makes us more tolerant of the
screaming of the crying woman's moaning
it's hard to be around all that crap
when your testosterone levels high right
so especially as a man if you decide to
be a second mother to some degree you're
chemically castrating yourself you're
losing your superpowers anyway
if you have a high testosterone level
you should want to see your children you
should love your children you should
protect your children i'm not saying you
shouldn't love them i'm saying you
should pick them up have fun with them
wow love you so much been two hours i'm
out see you that's how a father raises
kids he doesn't sit there all day every
day that's new age garbage it's not real
but given what women want out of a
relationship women don't know what they
want ah here we go they don't women want
things that the women think they want
things and then they get them and they
leave the dude women women don't have a
clue what they want i want a guy who's
sweet and sensitive and takes care of my
knees and thinks about me but
they're all out there none of you are
with them why because women don't want
that women don't actually want that
women want to be with a man they respect
women are only going to enjoy the time
with and end up
feeling in love with a man they
genuinely respect and unfortunately to
be respected some of the qualities are
detrimental to
the overall relationships let's say
happiness i know loads of women who are
with a dude they hate but they respect
him
like he makes me so mad but he is the g
and they stay with him as opposed to the
woman who's like well he's so nice to me
but you know and leaves so women need to
respect you as a man how's the woman
going to respect you as a man if no
other girl wants you how's the woman
going to respect you of a man if you're
putting her above all your boys how's
the woman going to respect you as a man
of an eye on the streets making money
how's the woman respect you as a man if
you don't respect yourself or other men
don't respect you respect is linked to
fear how is a woman respect you as a man
if people don't fear you there's a
problem with all these dudes out here
all these dorks man especially in the
crypto world i'm saying crypto because
you're a crypto girl right these nerds
will make a little bit of money and
wonder why their chick still leaves them
because you're just a rich nerd now
you're you're still a dork
you can still raise your voice and
nobody give a [ __ ] i'll still run up on
you and take everything you got
like you have to be a man worth
respecting and that's extremely
difficult to do and if you're going to
do all those things it's very very hard
to become a man worth respecting sitting
at home changing diapers and even if you
just make money on your laptop it's not
enough
what is it so what is enough so other
than other than um you know not changing
diapers um and you know just setting
around the world what is enough you talk
about being tall muscular you can shoot
guns all this stuff you talk about right
yeah some people aren't tools yeah so
what would you do if you wanted to all
right so firstly firstly let's accept
something
god has favorites
does he he certainly does okay and i'm
one of them as are you my dude look at
your nice beautiful smile thank you he
gave it to you god gave it to you right
so god does have favorites but it's not
even about that for the longest period
of human time for a man to be respected
for him to even be admired by society on
any level to some degree he had to be a
warrior that's what men did we fought
right so what then did we fall
so if you're out here as a man and you
have no battle in your life no conquest
in your life no form of war in your life
then what you do and it doesn't have to
be physical physical is the best example
of it every woman wants a boxer or a
cage fighter
of course you do
biologically yes because it means that
like if you know for me everything is
evolution right completely so it means
that if you know one day the
government's coming which they're coming
yeah um you know you want to know that
he can physically protect you and the
family right exactly so every woman
wants a boxer or a cage fighter but this
is a testament to the problem of the
modern world right right every single
man watching this knows that women wants
fires every single man watching this
would love to be able to say he's a
fighter but 99 of the men watching this
will not go fight because they are
afraid
they're all cowards they'll make up
every excuse under the sun oh it's busy
with my bitcoin oh dude
you're all a bunch of [ __ ] they are
[ __ ] all of them that's all they are
they're [ __ ]
and and women can smell that so if you
want if you want to have a woman who
truly respects you you need to put
yourself through war in some form now
what most men do is they avoid physical
confrontation because they're cowards
and they start doing fiscal
confrontation this is why men are so
obsessed with money because it's a
degree of conquest we can no longer walk
the earth and conquer land right it's
not like we the olden days we could just
walk around as the romans just chop
somebody up and take their land so now
we conquer the land
financially this is why men will work so
hard to be a ceo and give up his whole
life just to be a ceo because then he
gets to feel like he's conquering
something men have that innate desire
for conquest so that's the second best
thing i guess is to get rich i mean it's
not a bad thing to be rich certainly not
but if someone were to say to me look
you have to build the archetype of an
individual you have to build a man from
the ground up and he has to be respected
by both men and women he'd be a dude
getting in the cage kicking the [ __ ] out
of people and every man knows this and
every man can do it but they're all just
[ __ ] we suffer from
modern society and all of its problems
suffers from the fact that we are
plagued by monumental cowardice amongst
the male population
all men are cowards they're cowards it's
it's literally mind-blowing to me the
level of cowardice we're forced to
endure everyone's a [ __ ]
everybody
that why because it's been if they've
been deliberately designed to be [ __ ]
the femme centric systems has
deliberately installed frames in their
mind centric systems every single system
is femme centric that's quite
interesting because there's obviously
the idea that we have this patriarchy
which i don't believe in but now you're
literally saying it's the complete
opposite oh it's absolutely we have a
patreon
oh completely name of name a system
which doesn't favor the female every
court of law the justice system the the
legal systems it's all favorites assist
all favors are female even
even men we biologically are designed to
favor the female i'm telling you if
you're a police officer and you turn up
and a woman's crying you instantly to a
degree thinking this guy might be
there's a degree of guilt because we are
designed to protect females that's how
we feel right so all the systems are
fem-centric and the culture is
fem-centric everything we just talked
about a man how he's supposed to raise a
kid that's going to be mind-blowing to
some people and they're going to think
this guy's crazy
i should be at home changing diapers
pro you're supposed to be a warrior
you're supposed to be a warrior you're
at home changing diapers um okay so
there's this meme which is um bear with
me what is it like
good was it like strong men create um
what does it strong men create good
times good times good times great weak
men weak men create bad times and so on
and
are the strongest men of history were
they at home changing diapers did their
wife tell them they weren't allowed out
because we have a kid and i need help or
was he out there getting [ __ ] done and
this is the point so a lot of things i
say people may disagree with them people
may say i don't like the idea of that
even some women may sit there and go oh
that's wrong there's a whole bunch of
males we're going to try and pretend
it's not true but it's the absolute
reality of earth it's the absolute
reality of earth
it's the truth right and it's very very
hard to be a man worthy of respect if
you're going to stick to these centric
systems we're suffering from monumental
cowardice in every level the entire male
population from the complete bottom to
the absolute top is corrupted by
cowardice
let's talk about um something you
mentioned earlier um the scam sure you
guys know what we're talking about i
don't want to raise any red flags here
protecting the the good old algorithm
so
you have some interesting views on that
you as soon as um everything started and
everything was uh shutting down yeah
picking my words very carefully yeah you
started running basically you and your
brother correct so i hold the record and
i will state this here publicly i am
sure i hold the record for the
the quickest reaction to the lockdown
because a lot of people now who
understand that the things we were told
they were not necessarily true it took
them a while what is not true about
what's going on right now
can you be more specific
the the danger factor the number of
people who are affected by it the
reactions that we take and how they
should have a positive effect everything
it's all a sign up
every single level of of the entire i'm
trying to be careful of my words every
single level of the entire environment
is corrupted because we live in a world
now where everything is corrupted i was
saying this to someone the other day
there is nothing fair or just about the
world anymore every single system from
the police to the judges to the
governments the tax even the world
health organization even the doctors all
of it is corrupt head to toe all of it
is corrupted all of it
so the whole thing is a scam and i
like to think i hold the records at the
very very very beginning of lockdowns
all the people now who are
anti-mask and anti-lockdown they all
complied they all cut down and got
scared ooh the cold and me and my
brother we put on twitter you have to
time stamp within three seconds of this
garbage we're on planes flying to sweden
and belarus because the last countries
without lockdown
and that's basically because we took the
brave choice my brother and i sat there
and had a conversation we said
this virus might be the real deal we
might get really sick oh you you
actually thought for a moment well back
then it was when the people were
dropping dead on tv the italian
hospitals fall it looks like a real deal
right stuff was coming out of china it
looks crazy yeah okay so how do you know
what to do but me and my my brother
concluded well we don't know what to do
so let's take the bravest possible
choice because you can't hide from a
disease it's going to be here forever
it's going to get us eventually so let's
make the bravest choice let's die like
men let's charge it to gunfire because
we're not cowards it turns out we went
to sweden for two months in a wide open
country parking non-stop while everyone
else was locked in their houses and we
realized oh
everything's fine
now if every other man did that exact
same thing we wouldn't be where we are
two years later the reason we are
suffering because we are suffering
suffering the way we are suffering is
because of the monumental cowardice of
man
revolutions are nothing more than men
standing in one place and complaining
i'm screaming
can't even get men to do that anymore
too busy they're too busy they're at
home with the kids oh my wife said
that's my dirty dirt day to babysit it's
more it's peppa pig
more than that no no it's so much more
that's fun you say peppa pig actually
because boris johnson was talking about
peppa pig the other day
listen no but
but other than children staying at home
with the family all of you how do we
stop what is all of it leo my dear it's
all of it this is what i'm trying to say
you you we just started this interview
and you said it's unusual that i say a
man should have more than one female
right to you not unusual i just well it
is unusual i just don't necessarily it's
not what i'm looking for so for me i'm
just like i'm heartbroken that's okay
but no but the point i'm making is
everything translates right it's a
spider's web if you're gonna find a man
who's truly warrior minded who's truly
conquest minded who's truly hard to
govern
is he gonna get one chick and let her
tell him what to do with his life no
he's going to be that guy who does
whatever he wants
and and this is where we also tie into
loyalty because loyalty is a completely
misunderstood concept
you value loyalty oh absolutely but male
loyalty masculine loyalty is completely
misunderstood
all these dudes out here who are at home
with their wife thinking they're loyal
you're not loyal loyalty is having
options and returning to the same place
not only having one option they're very
different things if i walk into the
store and they only sell apples and i
buy an apple i'm not loyal to apples i
don't have a choice loyalty is walking
in the store where they sell all the
fruit
i buy apples six days a week
occasionally i get a big fat pineapple
and i go back to apples the day after
that's loyalty without choice there's no
loyalty so most these dudes and most
women who say he's loyal he's loyal he's
lame and he can't get nothing else
that's not loyal loyal is a dude who has
all those options and still is in love
with you that's what loyalty is so
masculine loyalty is completely
misconstrued and misunderstood anyway
the truth is about most these dudes who
talk about being loyal they couldn't get
something else that their life depended
on it nobody wants it
so i when i talk about a man having
multiple women i'm not even saying he's
gonna be a disloyal man i believe i know
a lot of men who don't talk about me i
have some friends who are some russian
guys they're multi-millionaires they
have a wife she's beautiful she's been a
bentley she's living the good life when
do you think when the russian mafia are
out to play he has no chicks
do you think he ain't running around a
bunch of barbie dolls no of course he is
but he goes home to his wife and his
wife's like he can do what he wants i
don't care about them i have to family i
have the kids and she's smart and he's
smart and it's a happy environment only
here in the west are you going to try
and find a mafia boss and say you're not
allowed to do that come on he's a g he's
a genie i understand it but from my just
for me personally i just don't think
that's something that i could yeah
you're living you're living in a fairy
tale my dear because you that means you
have to compromise no problem with it
because most these chicks out here and
most these dudes out here do compromise
everyone watching this compromises i say
this all the time if you were rich when
you met the partner you're currently
with you wouldn't even be with them you
think you love your wife no you don't
because if you're a multi-millionaire
you wouldn't even go with that [ __ ] so
everyone to some degree compromises if
you're saying that i value sexual
exclusivity above everything else that's
fine but you're gonna have to compromise
if i want if i want the most reliable
car i can buy i can't go into the
ferrari garage and say it has to be
reliable go buy a toyota then this is
what comes with the ferrari you get the
performance you get the beauty sometimes
it breaks down that's how it goes that's
what comes with a ferrari if you want a
top top top tier man
he's gonna do certain things and most
women intrinsically know this if you go
to one of these parties in miami and one
of these chicks is chilling with chris
brown do you think she believes he's
going to be loyal no doesn't matter it's
chris brown yeah i don't touch chris
brown
it was just an example my point is women
intrinsically understand a certain value
of male that they're not going to get
sexual exclusivity and they don't care
they only try and get that crap from
beta males it's only a beta male they
try and okay well you're not allowed
nothing out there that when you're
really really john and i agree with you
to
a very
large extent however i still want to
preview wrong one day you're not
listening
the biggest
bad boy you can find who is loyal to you
which is fine but the fact that he is
sexually exclusive to you means that for
some reason we don't know why yet there
is a human metric in which he does not
excel in every form so you can go out
there and like i said toyotas are really
reliable ferraris are unreliable you
might go out there get yourself a nice
bmw that's sure that's fine i'm not
saying he doesn't exist you know
yourself bmw i don't like bmw's well
that's
but when the ferrari pulls up next door
when i meet your dude i'll be like yeah
he's all right but how much less than a
hundred mil nah come on
whoa he's a broker i'll i'll bring you
wrong i'll pre-empt maybe he'll have
money but he'll lack somewhere else so
this is my point is that the the the
true masculine and true in the realm of
true masculine excellence one of the
benefits of such is sexual exclusivity
because females you have you have so
many choices
most men out here have no choice and the
very few men who are at the peak of the
human experience of a man have all the
choice and to find a man who has all the
choice which is extremely rare amongst
males like less than one percent and say
you're going to be with me and me only
it's hard it's hard why would he do that
why would he do that
i'll prove you wrong i'd love to prove
you wrong and look it's on the cards
we'll talk about this
and we'll see how i hope you have a
happy marriage i'm not saying you're not
going to find a nice guy i'm not saying
you won't find a guy who won't be loyal
to you i'm not saying any of that i'm
saying that that's compromise i
understand we'll see this compromise
we'll see whether we've compromised it's
compromise i want to go back to talking
about the the lockdowns and everything
like that right because it's getting
absolutely crazy um there are a lot of
um people hate when i say this but
i believe it so i'm going to say it
there are a lot of um
resemblances with 1940s in terms of us
and them and um you know creating a
second-class system of people so how do
we get out of this because all tyranny
does eventually come to an end does it
well we see it happens again history
doesn't repeat but it rhymes that's the
best thing that i've heard recently i
think it's amazing um but how do we then
come out of it i'm not saying in a
hundred years we're not gonna go back
into it but i'll be dead yeah you'll be
dead
what do we do my boy will be on the
streets don't worry so i mean that's why
i have to raise him right because you're
the next warrior do you have a boy no
but i'm gonna make about 20. so don't
worry about it
so um
yeah it's a difficult question to be the
pessimist in me kind of thinks that this
is different than all the other tyranny
they've tried to enact before because
they have a technological advantage and
they're getting to the point where they
might be able to ensure via technology
that they can keep a degree of tyranny
existing i really
pardon me not scared but part of me is
pessimistic in regards to the fact that
they have the tools now to put things in
place which are going to be extremely
difficult to break they're going to put
paradigms in place they're going to be
extremely difficult to break i've lost
all faith in humanity i didn't have much
before this and now i've lost it all
like really genuinely and
the biggest mental shift for me has been
before all this crap it was the blm
riots and trump and all this stuff and
everyone was screaming all cops are bad
and i'm like no come on we need the
police you know law enforcement
i'm going to change sides all cops are
bad
why are you enforcing this crap
it's insane the police are the police
are they out here the ones actually
cracking skulls it's amazing that a very
few elite can tell another select group
of the slaves to go and enact tyranny
upon the other group of the slaves and
they're gonna obey like this could all
end overnight if the police would wake
up and say no that's not fair but they
won't do it so all cops are bad so i've
lost faith in the law enforcement
systems i've lost faith in the judicial
system i've lost faith in governments to
the point where i sold all my real
estate did you yeah i refuse to even
hold real estate under a government i
hate them so much every single one of
them i can't stand any of them they're
all corrupt from head to toe you think
you own a house oh you own that house
right go piss off the irs tell me how
long you're in the house some cops are
going to turn up with a piece of paper
and you're out
you don't own anything the whole thing's
a scam the whole system is a scam and
you're talking about how it's going to
end
i don't know i don't know how it's going
to end my my answer to all of this
is the organization that i control and
run the war room
or what we do in our organization is we
try very very hard we prepare people to
be
adaptable
so in regards to their finances in
regards to getting multiple passports
that kind of thing because darwin said
it it's not the strongest that survives
it's the most adaptable this device
we're here in miami right now right if
miami locks down i'll bounce
i'm that guy i can i can live anywhere i
can go to tokyo tomorrow for the rest of
my life so i think the smartest thing
you can do in the current times is try
and prepare yourself or try and
construct a life which allows you to be
adaptable because nobody knows what's
coming next i don't know what's coming
next and nobody knows where to be it's
very very hard to be proactive in such a
chaotic environment you need to be
reactive and that's what the war room's
all about so
i'm trying to save myself and my people
that's the first thing i'm trying to do
i'm not really trying to save the world
no because a lot of these people out
here they deserve the slavery
you deserve it
listen
at the beginning of this crap when i saw
all the masculine influencers on twitter
the whole manosphere everything when i
saw them all all be [ __ ] all
everyone
you all deserve slavery oh now you've
changed your mind now you're anti-mass
you think i forgot i look stupid
elephants never forget right and it's
easy to be brave now the sentiment has
changed that's not being brave that's
just going with the flow the bravery was
required at the beginning when me and my
brother were getting arrested in germany
for refusing to wear masks you were at
home tweeting pro mask all these losers
all of them all the conservative all the
right wing all the masculine you were
all cowards all of you and you all
deserve the slavery which is gonna be
bestowed upon you if i if i had tweeted
something pro-mass
i would be issuing a public apology each
week i am sorry for the
i'm sorry for the fact that i aided in
the enslavement of man by believing the
propaganda machine i apologize i was
part of the problem these guys aren't
even sorry they're just gonna sit there
and start now changing it and tweeting
any mask and thinking that nobody
notices you're the reason we [ __ ] got
here i lost respect for so many people
so many people actually respected also
respect for all of them no warrior blood
cowards how you gonna roll next to me be
my boy if you're going to fall for
propaganda program how are you going to
go to water are you going to go to war
how are we going to set a police
interview if you fall for propaganda
programming
you listen police can arrest me today if
they come in and say your brother said
this i'm like no he did not shut up but
would you with you [ __ ] i might be
thinking maybe he was pro mask last week
all you men are cowards most of the
people out here deserve the slavery and
i really do think that there's going to
be a social split
even worse than before in regards to the
rich and the poor what's gonna happen is
you have people who have absolute
freedom and people who have complete i
think it's gonna be polarized it's gonna
get worse than ever have nots and have
yachts and i'm on the right side of the
equation so worst case i'll be in my jet
do my thing so worst case i know i'm
okay and i just have a duty to protect
the bloodline but
man i don't want to be pessimistic or
nothing but when the rally call came
at the beginning of the battle
i stood there by myself
i stood me and tristan understand
they're like where is everybody else and
you you can i don't need to name names
anyone who's on twitter every single
mascot account you can think of all the
big strong men the red pill alpha all
the conservatives that are
all cowards all of them you can go
through their accounts to see all of
them [ __ ] out [ __ ] all of them it's
crazy that's how we got it what can i do
i'm just one man leia i know i have
these superhuman powers i know i look
like that guy but i even i have limits
to my abilities baby there's only so
much i can do i think you're totally
right what we're gonna see is um like
the the middle class just gone right
completely it's going to be the
absolute freedom have nots and have
yours have nuts and have yours there you
go i want to be part of the have yours
that's the goal you are you will be you
will be don't worry so you so you spoke
about um
getting rid of all your real estate yeah
um and i understand that and i really
understand the um the pessimism you have
and the um
like the deep hatred towards this system
i i understand it you said something
really funny actually um a few years ago
yeah you said to me um when you had
nothing and you were living in america
they couldn't help you but as soon as
you left the irs knew how to get ahold
of you they knew how to call you oh yeah
they know how to find your ass when you
owe them money yeah but it's never the
you know like if they owe you money it
takes months and months and months to
turn up if ever right but if you owe
them money it's a whoo we better pay us
the whole thing's a scam it's like the
entire financial system which we can
discuss at length our entire financial
system is designed to steal wealth from
the poor and just turn it into numbers
on the screen of three destruction by
design yeah oh yeah the whole thing is
corrupt and when you understand the
system you understand that the system is
rigged to a point where most people do
not stand a chance to ever ever win so
let's talk about this in what way is it
rigged
it's rigged because
and i we can go down the economics of it
all yeah but my but my my very basic
premise of it is is that there's a whole
bunch of people out here who are
effectively slaves and when you're
you're a slave if you have a job in any
form effectively some slaves are better
paid than others but most people are
slaves in the days of slavery what would
happen is the slave masters would use
control and aggression and influence to
convince you to do work for free so what
they could do is it could get work out
of you with something that they can
generate from the sky right they can be
aggressive from the sky influence from
the sky a couple bullets are cheap
whatever it took and they could get your
labor now we have the exact same thing
but they just use fiat they use fiat
money if the people in charge of the
world can print unlimited amounts of
said thing and you'll give up your life
for certain amounts of said thing then
they own you they control you oh you
need a hundred dollars to do this print
off you go slave it doesn't matter it's
not real so who cares so the entire
world's a slavery system to some degree
maybe you can make enough of those
dollars and buy your freedom as i have
right but in general
it's a slave system and anyone who's out
here who still believes because it seems
to be there are some people who still
believe in like saving up and save my
money and if i'm really diligent and i
get a mortgage in 28 years i might own
the pro man it's a trap all of it is a
trap
have you ever met a rich person asked
them why that how they got rich and they
said saving no no
this is the biggest thing
complete lie and everything they teach
you about financial literacy is a lie
everything they teach you about wealth
creation is a lie everything they teach
you about what you're supposed to do
with your money and how you're supposed
to think of the lie they get your ass in
dead at the very very beginning so how
did you realize all this how did you
realize all this
god has his favorites no how did you
realize god has his favorite god can
instill potential into an individual but
doesn't mean that individual is going to
fulfill that potential something in the
environment has to happen i operate with
divine purpose absolutely not so how so
how did you realize all this i just you
know i i've always my entire life so i
was my father was a chess grandmaster i
was a chess player so at the age of
five i was indiana state chess champion
and when i was eight i was on my way to
becoming a fatty master so i was one of
those child chess geniuses i never
actually ended up becoming a chess
master because we moved to england my
father said in america blah blah blah
but
i've always been good at pre pretty good
at analyzing the chessboard and
even from a very very young age i just
understood and i don't know exactly
where i got it from i understood the
world is a scam all of it i was walking
to school one day walking to college
sixth form with my four friends in a
ferrari went past i was like yeah i was
like bro how do we get one of them it's
like oh don't know what do you mean
dunno doesn't it bother you he has 400
grand for a car doesn't that anger you
that he has 400 g's for a car and our
parents are broke or on a council estate
they're like well gus
that's the average man like the average
man has no fire inside of him i'm 16. i
couldn't sleep for three days because i
saw a rari i want a rari
i want one yeah now i have four right so
this is eight
only four but i have 22 cars as a whole
how many twenty two only twenty two i'm
sorry i'm sorry i don't want that every
year i hope you meet a rich man
but um but this is the exact point right
so i always had the fire inside of me
and what happened is growing up in luton
especially all the asian boys who are
driving these fast cars when you go to a
petrol station three in the morning and
a lambo and a rarity pull up you know
they're dealing drugs yeah you don't
look at them and go ah he worked hard in
school no way
no exactly so you know so i always had
an intrinsic understanding that the the
only way to truly get rich is to break
the system in some degree so when i was
going to school and the school was
trying to support the system they're
trying to
uh convince me that the system is the
best way to have a successful life i'll
sitting there going but everyone's
living the life i want
broke the system i don't believe in any
of this the final straw for me is i
actually did very very good in my
a-levels i was supposed to go to
university i got an a in business after
only three of the five tests because i
aced every single one i did this
advanced test this distinction got
distinction
and i was offered uh free university in
the uk and asked
ask off for business it was free
so cool i got to go you need for free
i'm such a clever [ __ ] good so
um but then they asked me to do a
personal statement oh i hated that yeah
so i'm like personal statement you
already said yes to me for free and
who's going to read this hi my name's
andrew i like to kick bugs who cares
like you've already said yes to me so
it's during two of her class i'm arguing
my two are saying why don't you need to
do a personal statement they already
said the yes to me then she's like
everyone has to do one i said no one's
gonna read this junk so everyone has to
do one i said you know what i won't go
then
that's how stubborn i was my mom went
crazy you threw away free university
over a personal so you could just wrote
one you could have done it listen i'm
gonna be a kickboxing champion don't
worry about it right so
when stuff doesn't make sense and you're
doing things for no reason but there was
a reason the reason to me was that
there's a personal statement doing a
past attempt doesn't make sense of
course right and and i saw that as a
genuine infringement that was oppression
i can't accept that no no i don't i know
i'm smart enough and i'm stubborn and
i've always been stubborn i'm like no
i'll be fine without your university
without your personal statement goodbye
i must be the only person to ever throw
away from university in the uk but i
didn't go best thing that ever happened
to me was not going to university thank
god i was a four year head start
everyone's out here in uni i was making
money i started off with a really basic
boring job i was carrying boxes of ice
in a fish market you know i wasn't doing
anything elaborate but at least i was
working this i was getting up at five in
the morning running to work working all
day running to the fight gym fighting
all night running home this is why i
respect this i didn't have a car yeah my
family didn't have a car right they was
literally just run i used to run nine
miles a day to get places i had to get
places i just run
so like i couldn't wear nice clothes
because i get sweaty right so i was this
guy for a track suit a t-shirt take my
t-shirt off i didn't sweat too much or
just run everywhere around losing you
just see me the crazy guy just running i
really want people if you don't know
luton please look up luton
it was bad yeah i grew up in a bad place
but um what did you do though you you
the you went to the fish fish market
fish market you while kickboxing correct
and then what did you do right so i
wonder how you made money you wanna know
the whole story of how i got rich yeah
it's a really long story every time but
yeah but i i've always said the point is
i've always had that fire inside of me
i've always had that desire inside of me
i think every man is born with a
masculine fire i think it's certainly
the reason why so many things in history
happen it's the reason why so many
armies try to conquer the land that look
like why why would the romans wake up
and look in a random direction and say
let's go over there whoever's there is
kill him that's inside of men there's
something masculine about conquest right
that fire has been dampened it's been
dampened by distraction and consumption
and all these things but for me i think
the fact that i was so broke i couldn't
really distract myself i couldn't
consume anything i couldn't buy anything
like so what do you do it was either a
life of crime or a life of punching
people in the face and getting paid for
it so i chose to get paid
and um
yeah the original question is why i
resisted the system i just i could feel
all these little triggers my whole life
of the system trying to oppress me and
every single person i saw living the
life i was aspiring to was outside of
the system even now to me now i consider
myself outside the system i'm outside
the matrix i can say what i want you to
get me fired who are you gonna do uh
you're gonna go go get me fired anyone
who's triggered by this get me fired
good luck yeah but you know like i love
living outside the system i always
aspired for it so that's the simple
answer i i i really think that
and be careful i say on youtube yeah i
don't want to get us taken down
demonetization i think you're working on
youtube but
any man out here with any kind of money
you have my network which is the war
room which is the primary network in the
world and besides us i don't think
there's anything else but you need to be
very very understanding of the fact that
if you're going to stay inside the
matrix and be a fully law-abiding
citizen for the next 10 years you'll get
crushed yeah you're going to get crushed
you need to either get another residency
to another country you need to get
political connections i'm telling you
everyone saw my twitter during these
lockdowns i traveled to 30 countries
during lockdowns partied i partnered
yeah so all cause i knew somebody i know
somebody everywhere i had a guy in
russia who gave me a business visa
through his company to go to russia
during closed call i know everybody
right so with my connections my network
and the number of passports i have which
is in excess of 10. i can do whatever i
want on those passports how does it how
does it work okay so like is your actual
name on it
this is youtube my dear i want to know
how it works this is youtube can you
tell me keep telling me to tell me and
tell
okay so i'm not plugging my organization
but one of the first things we do in the
war room is we have a we have a specific
section and a construct that helps
people obtain multiple residencies okay
because and the reason that's so
important is because if you only have
one passport then one government has
jurisdiction over your life correct and
i don't trust any of these governments
now the idea of living off-grid is
outdated the idea you're gonna go to
some hot in the forest and sit there
with a bunch of guns and that it's not
real right the new world orders here
we're all plugged into the system the
best thing you can do as opposed to
living off-grid is to live on as many
grids as possible because that allows
you that allows you a lot more
flexibility in the height of toronto
when i was traveling around when i
wanted to go into a country and said
you're not allowed in the country
americans are banned english people are
banned swedish people are banned ah
romanians are allowed in yeah cool so
i'm the same guy right i'm just whipping
out passports wait but is your name the
same on all the passports i've really
wanted to know that anyway the point is
the war room is the war room the
organization i run coppertape.com that's
something we specifically help with and
it's very easy to do there's ancestral
routes yeah there's a whole bunch of
roots it's not hard it's just a bunch of
paperwork and headache but we have a
team we have lawyers with people who can
help make all that happen so if you're a
man and you have any kind of money you
need to be
realizing that a degree of that money is
worth spending on trying to obtain
freedom and to obtain freedom you need
to have as many passports as possible
okay so we'll talk about the passports
after clearly got it okay i'll learn all
about this afterwards so let's talk
crypto um
you're very rude about um the crypto
people uh you know okay
am i rude i don't want to be rude
i don't want to be rude about crypto
people yeah i like them i'm a crypto
people yeah you're you're a crypto
person yeah and and i'm not
i know a lot of crypto guys who are cool
i have a lot of good friends i've made a
load of money with crypto yeah i love a
pump chain link right yeah i bought like
loads yeah i caught seoul at like six
dollars
yeah yeah so i i love i love crypto and
i love a crypto pump everybody does when
i say detrimental things about the
crypto community the point i'm trying to
make is that
many people out here especially men are
not prepared for wealth and when i say
they're not prepared for wealth they
haven't been through the struggle that's
going to allow them to become a man of
caliber before they find money they
haven't done the running to the fish
stall running to the gym getting punched
in the face for money they've never done
that so what happens when a 19 year old
kid catches a crypto pump on some junk
like sheba
now he's a millionaire fine but
a few things have happened first his
ability to work hard has now been
destroyed he will never work hard again
right because look how much money he
made with blind luck do you think he's
ever gonna go out there and get a job
and take a pay of 50 grand a year and
really dedicates never even if he lost
all that money the only thing he could
ever think to do is to just try and get
another pump he's a gambler now he's
effectively a gambler for the rest of
his life so his his whole work ethic's
been decimated that's the first thing
the second thing that happens when
someone like him catches a crypto pump
is because he has no life experience no
real-world experience no struggle etc
he's now
tristan calls them geese geeks geese
geese yeah like geese okay you for me
geese and fermis is another word he made
up but you just famished them they're
formicable
he made it up i didn't know what that
means
you're a chick you know what it means no
matter how many times you say they don't
like it says you turn up with your
pretty smile okay oh oh i love you
it gets for me stickers gets taken out
there's a game he gets for movies
yeah wick like he has no caliber he's no
no character right he's got money but
money is nothing more than an amplifier
money doesn't change who you are and the
problem with most these crypto dorks is
that they were dorks and now they're
rich dorks but you're still a door
yeah money is just an amplifier i'll
give an example
lambo pulls up yeah nerd gets out
now he's a super nerd oh some tech dork
he has a lambo who gives a [ __ ] to nerd
lambo pulls up
big man gets out now he's a mafia boss
so the point is that the lambo is not
what makes you a mafia boss the lambo if
you have all the other qualities will
amplify your qualities into that sphere
it's an amplifier money is an amplifier
and the point i'm making about wealth
and crypto when i insult these guys that
a lot of these guys don't have any of
the qualities they need to be amplified
they don't have anything worth
amplifying
if you're a man you've made a bunch of
money on crypto the smartest thing you
can possibly do is understand that the
traditional paths to wealth pre-crypto
taught you a lot about being a man if i
had to make millions the old-fashioned
way i'd have to learn to negotiate how
to learn how to handle stress learn how
to work really hard learn how to network
i'd have to learn i'd learn so many
things
these artists don't need to learn none
of that just mask
they don't know anything so my point is
that they've missed so many lessons on
the path to wealth that wealth used to
teach this is why women used to respect
money so much not just for the money but
you knew you were talking to an
ambitious connected smart intelligent
man now you can meet a man of money and
he's none of them things he's literally
none of them you just call crypto pump
it's a unique atmosphere we're in it's
temporary but it's unique
and when i say today when i saw the
crypto guys like look you have millions
and millions of dollars you need to get
some masculine
accountability not to plug but the war
room's exact kind of thing you need to
be in or you need to go down to a fight
gym etcetera etcetera you need to learn
all the lessons you missed on your path
to wealth and that's why when i insult
crypto guys that's what i mean because
i'll tell you something
i've been to these crypto events blah
blah blah i'm the only real g
okay okay maybe some of them have more
hundreds of millions of dollars than me
cool i'm the only one who ain't scared
i'm the one who'll throw down the street
i'm the only one who if a gun came in
the building would be looking to take
your sailor now everyone else will be
running like girls you think money makes
you something money doesn't make you
anything especially not in the harsh
reality of earth in the real harsh
realities of earth bravery makes you
something not your money your mad mass
ain't gonna save you some dude rolls up
you the blade decides to stick in your
[ __ ] neck it's garbage so these men
aren't men they're amplified dorks and
now they're all over twitter with their
little nfts and their little cartoon
faces together something i bought this
nft you still don't matter g you still
don't matter because you want nft
and and that's the whole problem with
the crypto world is that none of them
are actually very impressive people in
the re in real life
and that's why i insult them but i don't
want to insult them in a negative way
i'm trying to inspire you guys look you
have the money now use that money to
upgrade your character increase who you
are as a man
you know there's networks and things you
can join there's places you can go where
you're gonna have to genuinely be held
accountable and struggle and suffer and
go through some trauma so you can walk
with some pride as opposed to looking
like a complete
geek
there's no need for that you said
something interesting you said um when
you're lifting weights in the gym that's
your day off yeah it's my day off
because when i'm lifting weights in the
gym that's a day off because i spent my
entire career getting punched in the
face i i i had 87 professional fights
and for the majority of those fights
didn't even make any money
it's a couple grand baby i was i was
flying around the world to fight some
crazy kazak in armenia for like six
seven g's coming out with my hand broken
my face busted up like i've been to hell
and back and okay yeah it was
self-inflicted but
genuinely genuine is one of the best
things ever happened to me i thank the
lord i spent my 20s engaged in constant
combat i don't know how there's a
full-grown man out here if you're
watching this how are you a full-grown
man past the age of 30 and you've never
once had the balls once ever to get in
the cage in a fair fight against a
worthy adversary and you walk the earth
without shame
i'd be ashamed as a man if i spent my
entire twenties the height of my
masculine powers the height of my
ability and never once did i have the
balls to go and meet somebody in fair
combat ever once oh well i was busy busy
doing what you spent so much time on
pornhub you're a liar never busy cowards
all cowards and the crypto communities
man i'm telling you i go to some of
these crypto things i look around just
say you're all just so formulable i
could i keto everybody in this [ __ ]
room no one could even stop me be a
bloodbath it's a joke
it's a joke what's the problem with
pornhub
well i don't want to get into a side
career i used to run it don't go down
that path but
the problem
with pornhub
i'm not one of them anti-porn dudes i
know that conservatives are whatever i
don't really care but like everything in
life if it's consuming your mind and
consuming your thoughts then you have an
issue
and this is this is where we live in now
there's a whole bunch of these crypto
dudes especially who came and attracted
female with all their money isn't that
crazy they have all the money in the
world well you i think you said i think
it was you that said something
interesting however it was but it was
someone said it doesn't matter how much
money a man has because women still fall
in love with men that are broke
completely no no and also you know what
the the biggest thing about money with
girls is because people have this this
idea that money is going to help you get
girls let me explain how money and girls
works tell us i'll tell you
and i'll let you know if you're right
i'm right baby let's go
women love spontaneity
that's the first thing money facilitates
women love fun money facilitates women
love a man who's respected money
facilitates so money can help with
certain of the things that women find
attractive
it's very rare unless she's a hooker or
a gold digger that women are very very
interested in the actual number of how
much money you have or spend but what
women don't want is you
lacking the ability to be spontaneity
and stuff to be spontaneous or lacking
the ability to be respected because
you're broke or to feel like she has
fomo she's missing out and doing certain
things she can't go certain places that
her friends go because you're broke she
doesn't want that right so it's not the
money in and of itself that attracts her
it's the certain options that it gives
you as a man that she can find more
attractive i think that's the biggest
thing about it but here's the thing
about money most people don't understand
is that for the most beautiful women on
earth the reason they don't really
respect your money is
everybody they every guy they talk to
has money hmm
you're never going to go on a a date
with a broke dude so every single place
you go you don't pay so do you actually
care how much money that guy really has
or how much dinner really was not really
it was just dinner so the point is that
money is not enough to get a beautiful
woman it's enough to qualify you to try
because she ain't gonna go with a broke
dude and she's gonna go with one of ten
dudes she can go with and they all have
enough money maybe more one is more one
is less but they all have enough money
to give her the basic things she wants
bit dinner a bit fun holiday blah blah
blah so it just qualifies you to try so
if money is all you have and you have
absolutely no other qualities you're
going to lose to the dude who has money
and and the other stuff
that's the game money is like having
arms
like a chick a chick's not gonna get
with you just for having big arms but if
she can get with a dude she probably
wants to do to have some arms it's one
of them it's like i'm gonna give you
just for money but i don't know with a
broke guy so like women don't really
think about money that way they're just
like well every guy i go on a date with
is rich and men lie especially rich men
and there's a man with a million he'll
say he has 10. girl doesn't know
you know i mean like it's very rare you
someone like me with so much
quantifiable wealth
but like i have a [ __ ] six million
dollar car bugatti all this kind of
thing so with me it's hard to lie right
but there's a whole bunch of guys out
here who can catch a 400 grand pump and
they can convince the girl he's a
multi-millionaire for years
i can't confirm there's a caterer in the
kitchen
that blew my mind
i walked into that i walked in to go to
the bathroom and then there's this guy
just cooking and all this beautiful
fruit and of course i've got to eat i
see it so i told you i'm a man of god i
don't have a woman in my life who i eat
if i hire a catering company but um
no but the point i'm making is that
these dudes think if i get money i'll
get chick no you won't because you'll
get money and then the chick you're
after is still going to be dating
athletes superstars all these dudes they
have money too bro you think your board
ape is going to impress her
there's a ton which is um you can do
anything to a woman but you can't bore
her that's absolutely true so funny no
but it's true and and to get a little
bit dark it's true i knew a girl
in luton who was in an abusive
relationship right her man was always
hitting her screaming she was always
crying i want to leave him blah blah
blah problem was when she finally left
him in fact he got banged up for drugs
so he went to jail
she got some other guy a nice guy and
she was a complete prick to this dude
and she was so unhappy and the problem
was it's very very hard to be
interesting when your ex is a psycho
the new guy is boring
it's true i can see in her eyes i'd say
you're you're going home and you're
you're turning up two hours late and he
ain't even screaming
and you're bored aren't you well no no
no i said you missed the days of the
[ __ ] flying plates and [ __ ] because
it's because it's card women are
addicted to drama you watch tv shows
women watch serial killers documentaries
to relax
like this is the reality of females you
want drama you want excitement it's not
a bad thing you watch the kardashians
you don't want it smooth i don't watch
any of that stuff i'm just gonna put
that out okay but
as a generalization of course leia is
different i'm sorry but
as a generalization
the point i'm making is that you're
right sometimes women are attracted to
very very toxic men because toxic men
are not boring
you're never you're never bored with a
nut case and and then after or not after
a crazy guy you're trying to get with a
normal guy and you end up being very
very bored so you're right you can do
anything to a woman except for her a lot
of these dudes are out here treating
women like complete [ __ ] but she's
staying because she's not bored and it's
boring everywhere else in comparison
so it's it's just it's certainly true as
a paradigm it's true girls just want to
have fun cindy lauper there you go you
said something interesting as well see i
clearly follow everything i'm a fan like
i respect the hustle fully high five
fully respect the hustle may not agree
and then you know want to live the same
kind of lifestyle but i respect it you
said something which was um
when you wake up in the morning you
don't ask yourself if you're happy oh
completely not but what's funny about
that was a lot of your um a lot of that
kind of like masculine um like self-help
yeah um it's for men yeah but as a woman
i find that really helpful because you
said because you said um women just want
to be happy they just want to wake up
and feel happy yeah but you said no wake
up
and just what did you say wake up and
yeah so i created something where am i
doing yeah so so the basic premise is
that the paradigm of happiness is
completely misunderstood i believe that
because people always say to me oh well
you have all this money tape but are you
happy let's see if i'm going to be like
no
like i got i guess what they're hoping
i'm going to do yeah i'm like bro i'm
fine enjoy the bus no but the point is
the whole paradigm of happiness is
largely misunderstood
and we talk about happiness in society
as if it's the most important metric and
i'd actually argue that it's not an
important metric at all
and it's also really truly amazing how
what you define in your mind the limits
you set in your mind of what happy is
and what happy isn't becomes very very
true so i watched a very interesting
documentary once about colors colors
colors yeah and it was a tribe in africa
that used different words to describe
colors so to them
blue and yellow are the same color same
word right and also these two very
different shades of green and i'm
talking about like grass and a leaf like
basically the same sheet of shade of
green they're completely different
colors so when they showed them blue and
yellow and they said
can you tell the difference they're like
no it's the same color i can't tell the
difference between the blue and the
yellow but they couldn't see the
difference they couldn't see it because
in their in their mind it had one word
so because they grew up their whole life
and it had one word that those two
colors within that spectrum to them it's
just like it's one color they couldn't
see the difference just like we'd say
different various of pink it's all pink
they couldn't really see the difference
whereas the two very different shades of
green they're like oh yeah that's that
that's that oh they're completely
different so the point is their own
mental blocks their own mental barriers
where they had mentally decided to put
the breaks control their reality
and people often talk about being happy
and what they do is they talk about
being happy in the same way a child in
their very giddyish christmas morning
happiness you know like
i'm happy i'm happy that's never going
to be long lasting that's going to be
temporary if you were like that all the
time you wouldn't even get anything done
right you wouldn't even be a mature
adult so the idea that you're out here
searching for that feeling permanently
is astonishing as immature that is
certainly happy sure but i've changed
the paradigm of where happiness is for
me anything above distraught
is happy besides three or four
monumentally destructive events that are
going to happen throughout my life that
the loss of family member or something
unless i really really feel down i'm
happy so if i wake up it's not i'm
thinking if i'm happy or not if i'm not
devastated i'm happy it's it's black or
white if it's not black it's white so
even if i wake up and i'm furious and
i'm stressed and i'm pissed off i've got
much to do i'm still happy i've decided
i'm happy my happiness barrier isn't
this little giddy-ish at the top my
happiness is everything besides feeling
distraught that's how i've designed it
in my mind so i describe myself as a
happy person and i and i don't really
put much merit on my feeling of the day
i've got things to do i'm an adult i get
my [ __ ] done regardless of whether i'm
super happy or slightly less happy i'm
still happy and i still perform and
that's it as a whole so when i meet guys
oh i want to be more happy i'm like bro
that is a
stupid destructive way to try and live
your life to constantly self-analyze and
compare your happiness to how happy you
were at another period and how you're
gonna get happy again trying to get to
the top one percentile of happiness it's
it's stupid it's not real right
do you understand where i'm coming from
yeah i agree with you but i think what's
funny is that a lot of this um kind of
advice is given to men and you'll say
like a woman doesn't need it but i find
a lot of value in this kind of advice
that's i prefer so they say that women
give really bad advice right yeah they
say they give terrible advice i don't
necessarily agree or disagree but i i
seek out advice that men give to other
men for myself good good because i think
that a lot of the advice that men give
to other men is going to be harsher and
more logical and less emotionally led
but but i say this all the time to guys
who message me and saying they're not
happy i say two things i say firstly you
shouldn't be measuring or be concerned
with how happy you are shouldn't be
something that's in your mind or
something you're even thinking about
right you've got other things to think
about and other things to do that's the
first thing
the second thing is
[Music]
so the first thing the fact that you
will sit there and self-analyze yourself
to determine how happy you are out the
score of 100 is already a mental failure
that's a failure you should be busy
you shouldn't cross your mind the fact
you have time to sit there and go how
happy am i today oh i'm only this much
maybe i should be happier that's already
a mess up the second thing is and this
is the truth
most of you
in fact the large majority of you
don't deserve to be happy
why because they haven't done the work
it requires to be happy you're not a man
of genuine excellence in every human
metric you don't deserve to be happy
you're sitting at your computer with
your board ape and your nfts and four
million dollars but you're fat and
you're boring and you stick and you
expect yourself to be happy you don't
deserve to be happy you don't deserve it
you haven't worked for it beauty lies on
top of the mountain my friends you have
to climb it you have to get all the way
up there to see the peak and this
amazing view let me tell you something
i'm happy because all i've done is
suffer that's all i've ever done is
suffer this is how i got here suffer my
life's been nothing but suffering and
trauma that's how i got here that's why
my that's what my world view is so
brilliant that's how i can wake up and
as long as no one has a gun to my head i
am happy because i have suffered
you
ladies and gentlemen haven't suffered
enough and if you haven't suffered
you're never going to be happy happiness
lies atop a mountain if it's just laying
all over the floor and anyone can pick
it up it has no value people's entire
mental model is skewed you look you're a
crypto guy right you believe in nfts
nfts the whole point of them is that
there's one
it's the scarcity that provides the
value if things are not scarce there's
no value to it yeah right so it doesn't
matter what it is doesn't matter if it's
financial doesn't matter it's even a
good body right the fact that a guy has
big arms the reason that has value is
because it's rare if every dude
naturally had big arms by default it
wouldn't have a value so you're talking
about happiness as it should just be
laid all over the floor if everyone
could pick up happiness without trying
you still wouldn't be happy because it
wouldn't have value and you'd be aiming
for a new you'd be looking for a new
attention of happiness you're looking
for something else you just raised the
paradigm and people who are out here
trying to find happiness without trauma
and suffering those are the guys who get
addicted to drugs alcohol all this crap
because you're trying to find temporary
happiness you're going to find happiness
through pain that's where happiness
comes from as a man and i'm not i know
you say you take some of my advice
etcetera etcetera i love male advice
yeah perfect but it's the struggle that
adds to value to things the reason i'm
going to love my cars so much is because
i had nothing and now i have one walk
nine miles i walk nine miles now i get
to do it in a lambo it's beautiful if i
was born into money and was just given a
lambo for my birthday i wouldn't even
appreciate it that's the reality so most
you men out here don't even deserve
happiness you come to me talking about
happiness you don't deserve and you know
you don't deserve it because you're
coward and you're lazy and you're weak
you don't deserve happiness it's good
you're unhappy that's your own mind
telling you you need to do more because
if you were genuinely genuinely making
an impact on the world and exerting your
entire masculine force out into the
universe if you were genuinely doing
that you'd find happiness so if you're
sitting there feeling depressed it's
because you know you're lazy you know
you're not working very hard i don't
want to rant on your podcast no it's
good i'm enjoying it i'm enjoying it it
really it's just like the whole idea
that a good doesn't exist without evil
right so good doesn't exist without
batman yang 100 bling and yang light and
dark
we we don't want to feel what's the
exact same
we all love the sun we don't want to see
the rain but you can't rain uh i've not
heard this i can't remember we all love
the sun we don't want to feel any pain
but you can't have a rainbow without a
little rain something like something
something like that but no this is as
old as human time right and the whole
people especially men if you have this
paradigm in your mind that you should
just be happy by default without trying
without working without any kind of
struggle without any negatives in your
life and you're just gonna be a happy
person and you're always just gonna be
laughing and giggling in the top one
percent that's asinine it's not real
it's a stupid mentality to have i don't
care how happy you are you have work to
do if any man comes to me and he's
looking for guidance i say i don't i
don't really care how happy you are
because you're fat
you got work to do come talk to me when
you have a six-pack otherwise i don't
care you have too much to get done to be
talking about happiness most you men out
here have so much to get done before you
talk about happiness it's amazing to me
how little work the majority of people
out here are doing i like you're a
full-grown man living in a transitionary
period of humanity where the entire
financial system is broken and trillions
of dollars are created from the sky and
you don't have a single million
you don't have one
they're all they're everywhere like how
do you be a full-grown man and not be a
millionaire like are you dumb
how many millions are too many millions
because when we met in london something
that i haven't forgotten which i thought
was hilarious was you and your brother
said to me
look 20 million is good right i don't
think you need more than 20 million in
life if we have 22 million we have an
emergency meeting and we sit down and
say how can we blow those two millions
yeah completely so no i think twenty
twenty we've raised the bar i thought it
was funny yeah 20 to 30 million is
enough right anything above that i
believe the money no longer has value
and it's better to spend on a human
experience that's what i believe because
if you have 30 million or 40 million
your life's not going to change if you
have 30 million or 100 million your
life's not going to change your life's
the same so i'd rather splunk all that
money on human experience and amazing
things and try to get the best out of
the physical world we live in that's
that's what i personally believe in so
that's enough to to survive but it also
depends there's some people who are out
here i see a lot of crypto guys and a
lot of other people they're talking
about generational wealth i'm gonna save
my bitcoin there they really want their
children to be rich i don't want my kids
to be rich that's another
mindset i have i really want to die
taking most of my money with me i do not
want rich children really absolutely i
agree with that but what do you i
understand why it's obvious but in times
of your money what would you do with it
you don't don't just give it i mean you
just give it to some institutions some
[ __ ] charities
nothing like that so what i'm going to
do is i'm going to financially
incentivize my children so yes they're
going to have the ability to be so when
i used to have to run to the gym and
suffer and fight and at the end of it i
still didn't have food my boy is gonna
go through all that and he's gonna fight
and then i'm gonna give him some money
but still he has to suffer still he has
to fight still he has to win still he
has to run to the gym and back et cetera
et cetera the worst thing you can do for
a child is racing bridge and and so
that's the worst thing you can possibly
ever do so i have no interest in that
whole general relational wealth crap but
yeah i find it i find it but if you want
to build generational wealth you you
just don't want them to have an easy
life you want them to you don't want
them to suffer exactly how you did
i want them to suffer i want them to
suffer a lot a lot yeah but maybe maybe
in a slightly different way right but
they're i'm going to make sure they go
through a lot of pain because it what
makes them mad it's what makes him a
character right it's extremely important
but i find it i really find it
remarkable when i meet
men who say they work hard and i'm not
trying to be i'm not listening i'm not
being elitist i'm not being a horrible
guy here because i'm from the streets
right i'm from the ghetto i'm not
talking about if you're a taxi driver or
whatever you've been texting your whole
life i'm not trying to sit here and [ __ ]
on you i'm not trying to do that i'm
saying that especially if you're a
younger man and you have you have access
to the internet and you're paying
attention to the things that are going
on in the world and you do your studying
and you're not hard to do some work well
uh if you're not afraid of work i find
it amazing those guys out here are still
broke
how can you be poor in the modern
society that we live in like
there's money everywhere there is it's
literally everywhere like so when i see
a dude he's like oh yeah man i'm broke
i just look at him and go you're not
trying hard you're not trying hard yeah
you're simply not trying on it if i can
do it from a single mother effectively
from a loot and council estate
to to ultra high net worth individual
then i i refuse to accept others can't
do it and people say oh yeah but you did
this or you had this blah blah blah
perhaps you know but i don't i don't
operate within that realm i'm not going
to be softer on anyone else than i was
on myself of course if i held myself to
such a crazy high standard and i was so
accountable and so difficult and so hard
on myself why am i going to be soft on
you i was extremely hard on myself i go
sparring for four hours and i got hit
once i was curious
you want to be hit more no i don't want
to get hurt you don't get hit i don't
get it okay
i don't want to get touched right i got
hit once i couldn't i couldn't sleep for
days
i was absolutely a perfectionist right
and then there's dudes out here are just
just sloppy right they're sloppy with
their entire life they're just sloppy
and they're like oh yeah well you know
just wear the mask and they deserve
what's coming they deserve what's coming
from slavery they're amateurs
we live in we we're really living in a
paradigm shift where the professionals
of life and when i say the professional
explaining that means in a minute but
the professionals of life are gonna
genuinely excel where all of you
amateurs are gonna fail most people most
men especially they live their life like
complete amateurs i don't understand how
they even function they don't know their
own passport number they haven't
memorized men aside though like people
in general they're amateurs i sometimes
i do wonder how people have gotten to
certain ages and how they're even
functioning getting offended by very
simple things i'm just like like how
have you gotten to an age lived your
whole life how on earth are you
functioning if that's going to upset you
absolutely i don't understand how that
even examines and that's how they stay
inside the matrix right you need to
exert a degree of professionalism that's
what i'm saying earlier about the crypto
kids if you have money great fantastic
you've ticked that off but there's a
whole bunch of other areas of
professionalism you need to excel in you
can give me any firearm on the planet
right now i'm going to hit the target
you can give me any you give me any car
in the world basically i'll run the cops
like i'm that guy you need to become
that guy you know it's practice you need
to go do it but these dudes just don't
do it we're suffering from cowardice we
talk about all the problems in the world
it's easy to talk about them all but you
can narrow them all down to the exact
same thing
cowardice masculine cowardice all of it
all of this is masculine cowardice
that's all it is and and man i see full
grown men out here like wearing a mask
you're scared of you're scared of air
you're scared of air
probably the biggest dating filter there
is
i walk around miami oh he's got a mask
the medicine the medicine sorry sorry
sorry sorry the medicine the medicine
the medicine the medicine yeah but it's
it's incredible it really is incredible
to me that that's the paradigm shift we
live in and it's amazing to me that some
of the things i say are seen as so
controversial because i don't think i
see anything that controversial i'm
saying look have some balls do what you
want to do stick to your your
imperatives as a man try and get rich
and try and try to some degree live with
a life of freedom that's all i'm trying
to say see i really agree with you and i
don't think anything's that
controversial but before we started this
you said that you do piss some people
off right no i don't really understand
why i've got to be honest i actually
don't because i don't think anything
you've said is unfair but but what i do
is see i am i'm a sound board and what i
do is i annoy the majority of men
because if you're gonna talk to me or
listen to me or compare your life to
mine nearly any man on the planet is
gonna to a degree be inferior so you
need to humble yourself this is the
truth men need to humble themselves
because
like talking about crypto right yeah i'm
all right especially
rich yeah but i'm also rich and i'm also
tall and strong and smart and i can keep
this [ __ ] out of you yeah and i've got
all these and i've got political
connections and i'm living a life of
freedom and
like you're rich but you're afraid to go
outside someone's gonna rob you so it's
very difficult for men to compare
themselves to me and not to some degree
take an l so they have to humble
themselves so what happens when i talk
to people is either they go this is
inspirational i want to learn from this
guy he has so much to teach he's right i
need to become a professional i need to
be well-rounded i need to join his
network i need to know the people he
knows i need to have all these assets
and these these uh connections et cetera
et cetera or people go ah he's just so
arrogant he's crazy and i'm sitting home
with my wife and i raise my kids and
he's crazy but no i'm not crazy
it's defense mate it's coke that's cool
it's hardcode and
and lots of dudes have cope it's kind of
amazing there's also something that's
primal amongst men that women probably
don't really know about but
as a man when you meet another man who
you know can kick the [ __ ] out of you
it bothers you even if they don't want
to admit it so even if i meet a dude and
i'm really polite i'm like hey bro nice
to meet you
part of them is kind of like [ __ ] this
stuff oh no because they know i'll mess
him up he knows i'll mess him up and
it's something intrinsic about
masculinity it's kind of like when some
girls hate girls who are prettier than
them they're all girls but some girls
like oh [ __ ] that but she speaks right
it's the same kind of thing but it's
just violence related right so there's
that aspect
yeah it's ridiculous but it's primal and
you can try it and you can also tie into
the fact that they don't like people who
are richer than them right men are like
people who richer than them they're
survival yeah
yeah so so when they meet me and i'm
more important than them richer than
them i beat the [ __ ] out of them and
then i take all these boxes they just
sit and go all he's crazy i don't like
gaming i don't want him on my podcast
blah blah blah i've had people record
podcasts with me and refuse to put him
out what did you say the same [ __ ] i'm
saying now the truth
the truth but you weren't like more like
inappropriate or harsher or not written
not really because i don't think you
said anything too bad
look i don't think so i don't know maybe
they're worried you go down i go down
cause i just said i agree with
everything you just said basically see
you in jail literally so i'll get us out
i got phone calls i got phone calls
don't worry about it
yeah i'll get it so um okay what is the
final goal then because every day you're
always like you know every day i'm
hustling every time i'm survived you
know you don't take a day and you do
take days off but it's not like a day
off right yeah um like like we said
earlier even lifting weights is your day
off right right like for me lifting
mates is lifting weights it's not a day
off so
what's the final goal like where do you
see yourself in like 20 years that's a
good that's a good question
and i believe i have a duty to protect
the bloodline
i have a duty to my last name it was
instilled within me my father yeah tate
my father's on the greatest man on the
planet unfortunately is no longer with
us which now promotes me to the greatest
man on the planet so i have about your
brother you equally greatest men all
right yeah we should we share them
so
i have a lot of work to do and i think
that
the duty i have to my bloodline
it depends the exact path i'm gonna take
i don't know if i'm gonna have 20 sons
with 20 women we're going to find one
woman who might give me two or three et
cetera but i think the family is a
beautiful thing but the nuclear family
as it's told within this trad calm
conservative that's garbage if you were
to ask me now to design my ideal life
like if i could just design it i'd have
three or four sons in moscow three or
four sons in kazakhstan maybe two or
three sons in mongolia you know my three
chicks inshallah my three wives and uh
they'd all be training hard becoming
warriors of earth all carry the last
name tate and in the future as much as
people go tate you can't do that you
can't kids with all these women you
can't do that blah blah blah in the
future when the dystopian when the
machines arrive when the terminators
turn up and you're like where's john
connor roast john connor oh he was an
act of fiction but there is a man there
is a man who does exist there's a man
who's real he's from deep in mongolia
and his name is emery andrew tate the
fifth and he's going to rise up because
even i am human i know it's hard to
believe even i have human i'm human
right and there's limits to my power
time is in the fire in which we all burn
even i will get old but when i am old i
need to make sure i've done my job
because it would be a detriment it would
be unfair to humanity for me to not
create clones of myself to protect the
future so that's my plan my plan is to
protect the future via my offspring
that's my plan
okay
plug whatever you're doing so the war
room yeah follow him on twitter
he's also got a great um youtube where
you are very unfiltered um there's a
hilarious thing about how why women
should cook and men shouldn't cook which
by the way as somebody who's like
running her own show
i understand am i right because
opportunity costs completely but like
again gender aside like i have like
cooking you know opportunity costs the
amount of time i waste cooking it's
insane the amount of business schools i
could have fit in in that cooking period
completely completely i
the youtube is that tape speech check it
out but i i have a i say some things
that sound outlandish like if you're
broke you should never cook you're like
what are you talking about but it's
opportunity cost you ain't got time to
waste i know bro i know broke dudes out
here cooking breakfast cooking lunch
cooking dinner you're wasting how many
hours no wonder you're broke like
cooking should be a luxury for the ultra
rich like either that or hire a chef
you've got stuff to do with your life
you're out here broke as a joke sitting
there with a frying pan you're like is
that you're gonna that's how you're
unless you're planning to get rich these
people have no no understanding of her
no understanding of the world so yeah
cooking's a massive opportunity cost if
you're a man out here and you cook meals
and you're not a millionaire you're
[ __ ] up you're [ __ ] up your life so
stop so take speeches to youtube
at cobra tate is the instagram twitter
who knows how long i'll be around of wu
dan what is over down by the way
because i am of udaan
i don't know what that is you don't know
i i come from mudan
again
is a mystical mountain right i've
existed can't you tell leia that i'm far
too intelligent yes yes yes i'm far too
intelligent for the age 35 i've been
i've existed for 5 000 years i'm a
reincarnation of do you actually believe
you're incarnated
i don't know i should say yes or no so
you say the truth
it's not so much about believing belief
has nothing to do with it it has nothing
to do with belief
the the fact is that i am the last of
the warrior class
and the my whatever occupies me whatever
inspires me to act in the way i act
right
you say this i don't have divine purpose
i say divine purpose whatever it is it's
ancient okay right
and
for 5 000 years whatever fire is inside
of my soul has wandered the
the the forests of udaan
in battle against evil
the ninja shogunate you understand yeah
okay so all right so there was a in
ancient times there was a ninja spirit
which is engaging against the evil
samurai and that is the the spirit which
is inside of me today so i descend from
udon
and and when i talk about the bloodline
it is my job to instill the same warrior
spirit in my offspring i will not have
sons who are too busy buying nfts and
saying oh i made a little bit of money
and have skinny little arms and go to
crypto conventions and be dorks i will
not have nerds as children i refuse to
have a nerd carry the lame tape if my
son is a nerd one of us has to die him
or me and i'll challenge him to mortal
kombat jesus christ
do you mean that yeah that's a bit of an
exaggeration but it sounds cool right
that sounds good i understand it um
andrew thank you so much for chatting
with me welcome it's always really
fascinating to hear your perspective on
things and yeah i appreciate it and
honestly i really respect the hustle
thank you very much thank you uh
yeah that's everything yeah thank you
guys thanks for watching don't forget to
hit the subscribe button hit the like
button and uh we'll see you next week
[Music]
[Applause]